Welcome to the
"For All Mankind Podcast."
I am your host, Krys Marshall
We're gonna talk about the show,
we're gonna meet some
real-life astronauts,
and chat with some of my
favorite folks from the show.
Super excited.
Here we go.
Let's go make history.
When you're in Earth orbit,
we're above the atmosphere,
but we're still below
the Earth's magnetic field.
We're really getting into
the meat of the show.
Those more sci-fi inklings,
and the bigger picture
is starting to get revealed.
NASA would have pushed
the technology forward.
An electric car would have been
possible in the 80's.
I wanted to kind of rekindle that sense
of wonder and awe about flying into space.
We came in the name of science,
we came in the name of discovery,
and of a new frontier.
I mean, it's what Ed says,
we came for all mankind.
Once we do this thing,
there's no going back.
KRYS: Say good-bye, guys.
- SONYA: Bye, thank you!
- MATT: Bye, thanks, Krys.
KRYS: Great. Thank you, guys!